primero calcularemos la solubilidad
molar del cloruro de plata en agua pura
y luego vamos a comparar la solubilidad
que obtengamos en el inciso a con la
solubilidad que obtendremos en el inciso
b y en el inciso b ya no tenemos agua
pura tenemos algo de amoniaco presente
tomamos un poco de cloruro de plata
sólido este de aquí y lo ponemos en agua
pura y una parte del cloruro de plata se
disolverá pero la mayor parte
permanecerá en estado sólido el cloruro
de plata es un compuesto poco soluble
así que esta es mi pequeña montaña de
cloruro de plata no disuelto pero parte
de este si se disuelve y entonces
obtenemos nuestra solución saturada de
cloruro de plata hay cationes de plata
+1 en solución y también hayan iones
cloruro en solución
nuestro equilibrio de solubilidad para
encontrar la solubilidad molar del
cloruro de plata continuamos escribiendo
nuestra tabla y tenemos nuestras
concentraciones iniciales nuestro cambio
y finalmente nuestras concentraciones en
equilibrio antes de agregar el cloruro
de plata no tenemos iones en solución
por lo que las concentraciones iniciales
de nuestro producto serán
tenemos cero para la concentración de
nuestros iones una parte del cloruro de
plata que agreguemos se disolverá por lo
que perdemos una cierta concentración de
nuestro cloruro de plata llamaremos a
eso x estamos perdiendo una cierta
concentración de nuestro cloruro de
plata si vemos nuestras proporciones
molares por cada molde de cloruro de
plata que se disuelve obtenemos un mol
de cationes de plata +1 en solución por
perder x aquí estamos ganando x de este
lado para la concentración de cationes
de plata en solución y ya que nuestras
proporciones molares son aún 1 a 1 si
disolvemos un molde cloruro de plata
ganamos un molde aniones cloruro por
aquí obtenemos más
x
en equilibrio nuestra concentración de
cationes de plata es equis y nuestra
concentración de aniones cloruro es x
escribimos nuestra expresión de
equilibrio y ya que se trata de nuestro
equilibrio de solubilidad escribiremos k
p s
nuestra constante del producto de
solubilidad es igual a la concentración
de nuestros productos la concentración
de a
más elevado al poder del coeficiente
elevada a la primera potencia por la
concentración de los aviones de cloruro
cl -
elevado a la potencia del coeficiente a
la primera potencia podemos evaluar
nuestra constante del producto de
solubilidad a 25 grados es 1.8 por 10 a
la menos 10
escribimos aquí 1.8 por 10 a la menos
diez y esto es igual a equis por equis
será igual a equis al cuadrado podemos
sacar la calculadora y resolver para x
tenemos la raíz cuadrada de 1.8 por 10 a
la menos 10
calcular la raíz cuadrada de eso y
entonces x es igual a 1.3 por 10 a la
menos 5 si queremos redondear eso
tenemos que x es igual
a 1.3 por 10 al menos 5 volar
esa es la concentración dedicamos
nuestros cationes de plata a uno en
solución también es la solubilidad molar
del cloruro de plata
eso es cuánto podemos disolver no es
mucho es una sola bilidad molar muy
pequeña el cloruro de plata es un
compuesto poco soluble veamos qué sucede
cuando tenemos amoniaco presente en
lugar de agua pura así que con tres
molar tenemos algo de amoniaco presente
ahora qué pasa cuando el amoniaco está
alrededor del camión de plata obtenemos
esta reacción un catión de plata más dos
moléculas de amoniaco nos da lo que
conocemos como unión complejo aquí y
mostramos lo que sucede si tenemos un
camión de plata
1 tenemos dos moléculas de amoniaco así
que déjame continuar y dibujar mis dos
moléculas de amoniaco y ciertamente no
está dibujado a escala así que dibujaré
una vez de lado
y otra de este lado
recuerda tus definiciones de ácido y
base de louis una base de louis es
aquella que puede donar un par de
electrones y eso es lo que sucederá aquí
el nitrógeno tiene un par libre de
electrones y cada molécula de amoniaco
va a donar un par de electrones a
nuestro camión de plata +1 así que el
amoniaco está donando un par de
electrones por lo que éste deberá ser
nuestra base de louis y el camión de
plata +1 está aceptando un par de
electrones por lo que deberá ser nuestro
ácido de louis la formación de unión
complejo es una reacción ácido base de
louis y observa la constante de
equilibrio para esto es 1.6 por 10 a las
7 k efe se refiere a la constante de
formación y este es un valor muy alto
para la constante de equilibrio
el equilibrio se inclina hacia la
derecha y este es un guión complejo
estable cualquier ión de plata que esté
en solución si tienes amoniaco presente
el amoniaco tomará ese jon de plata y
esencialmente remover a los iones de
plata de la solución si volvemos aquí
arriba y pensamos en equilibrio
si tenemos amoníaco presente estaremos
removiendo cationes de plata de la
solución estamos disminuyendo la
concentración de cationes de plata
estamos disminuyendo la concentración de
uno de nuestros productos y el principio
del eid le dice que si estamos
disminuyendo la concentración de uno de
nuestros productos nuestro equilibrio se
desplazará a la derecha para hacer más
por lo tanto entre más se incremente la
solubilidad del cloruro de plata
más se disolverá porque el amoniaco está
presente debido a la formación de
nuestro ión complejo así que agregamos
algo de amoniaco si añadimos algo de
solución de amoníaco aquí podríamos
lograr que nuestro cloruro de plata se
disuelva porque es más soluble debido a
la formación de los iones complejos
digamos que añadimos suficiente solución
de amoniaco y logramos disolver todo
nuestro cloruro de plata aquí esa es la
idea agregar suficiente amoniaco
ocasiona la formación de unión complejo
que incrementa la solubilidad de nuestro
cloruro de plata esperaríamos un
incremento en su luz
de nuestro compuesto iónico poco soluble
cloruro de plata ahora vamos a hacer los
cálculos vamos a encontrar la
solubilidad del cloruro de plata en
nuestra solución 3 molar de amoniaco
ahora vemos dos reacciones vemos el
equilibrio de solubilidad para nuestro
compuesto poco soluble y también vemos
la formación de nuestro ión complejo
ahora sumamos esas dos reacciones para
obtener nuestra reacción neta de lo que
sucede sumamos estas dos reacciones para
obtener una red
visión
de lo que sucede cuando añades cloruro
de plata en amoniaco tenemos cationes de
plata en nuestro lado reactivo y en el
lado de los productos así que podemos
quitarlos entonces para nuestros
reactivos netos tenemos cloruro
plata sólida más
monjack o
y en el lado de nuestros productos
tendríamos nuestro complejo y nuestro a
nyon cloruro tenemos nuestro
complejo
y también tenemos a la unión cloruro cl
- esa es la reacción eta y si sumas esas
dos reacciones para obtener la reacción
neta tenemos una nueva constante de
equilibrio que llamaré acá y si sumas
dos reacciones para obtener tu nueva
constante de equilibrio multiplicas la
constante de equilibrio de estas dos
reacciones así que acá es igual a cape s
por k
efe si haces esos cálculos 1.8 por 10 a
la menos 10 por 1.6 por 10 a las 7
obtendrás tu nueva constante
de equilibrio y no lo haré aquí solo
para ahorrar un poco de tiempo pero si
haces eso obtendrás 2.9 por 10 a la
menos 3 nuestra meta es encontrar la
solubilidad molar del cloruro de plata
en nuestro amoniaco escribimos nuestra
tabla y si nuestras concentraciones
iniciales nuestro cambio y luego nuestro
equilibrio supongamos que estamos
empezando con nuestra solución de
amoniaco y no hemos añadido nada de
cloruro de plata aún volvamos aquí
arriba y veamos qué concentración
teníamos empezamos con una solución 3
volar de amoniaco así que déjame
escribir eso aquí nuestra concentración
inicial para el amoniaco es 3 molar
no hemos añadido nada de nuestro cloruro
de plata y no tenemos ninguno de
nuestros iones complejos nuestra
concentración inicial de nuestro ion
complejo es cero y tampoco tendríamos
algo de nuestro año cloruro por lo que
esa concentración sería cero también
ahora añadimos nuestro cloruro de plata
a nuestra solución de amoniaco y algo de
nuestro cloruro de plata se disolverá
por lo que representaremos a esa
concentración con una equis perderemos
una cierta concentración de cloruro de
plata escribimos menos x luego veremos
nuestras proporciones molares la
proporción molar del cloruro de plata
sólido comparada con el amoniaco es de 1
a 2
por lo que para cada mol de cloruro de
plata que se disuelve perderemos también
dos moles de amoniaco escribiremos menos
2x aquí para nuestros productos si un
molde cloruro de plata se disuelve
hacemos un molde nuestro ión complejo si
perdemos x por aquí ganamos x por aquí
para la concentración de nuestro ión
complejo y lo mismo pasa con el lyon
cloruro porque nuestro coeficiente es un
1 vamos a ganar x para nuestra
concentración de unión cloruro en
equilibrio nuestra concentración de
amoniaco s 3 menos 2 x nuestra
concentración de ión complejo es equis y
la concentración de añón cloruro también
es x luego escribimos nuestra expresión
de equilibrio entonces tenemos que k es
igual a la concentración de productos
sobre los reactivos veo un millón
complejo por aquí así que escribimos la
concentración de nuestro ión complejo y
elevamos la concentración a la potencia
del coeficiente
a la primera potencia esto lo
multiplicamos por la concentración de
nuestro a nyon cloruro elevado al poder
del coeficiente que en este caso es un 1
también tenemos algunos reactivos aquí
así que dejamos al cloruro de plata
afuera porque es un sólido pero tenemos
al amoniaco todo esto se divide por la
concentración de nuestro reactivo
esto es sobre la concentración de
amoniaco
y observa que nuestro coeficiente es un
2 necesitas tener un 2 aquí
luego evaluamos nuestra concentración de
equilibrio nuestra concentración de
equilibrio del amoniaco es 3 - 2x
nuestra concentración de equilibrio de
ión complejo es equis y nuestra
concentración de equilibrio de la unión
cloruro es x en la derecha tendríamos x
a la primera potencia por x a la primera
potencia todo dividido entre 3 - 2x al
cuadrado y luego podemos evaluar nuestra
constante de equilibrio acá
que es 2.9 por 10 al menos 3 esto es
igual a del lado derecho tenemos x al
cuadrado
déjame escribir eso x cuadrada entre 3 -
2 x al cuadrado
es igual a 2.9 por 10 al menos 3 y
entonces lo que podemos hacer es que
estos dos términos están al cuadrado por
lo que podemos decir que todo esto del
lado derecho está al cuadrado y luego
podemos obtener la raíz cuadrada de
ambos lados obtenemos la raíz cuadrada
de 2.9 por 10 a la menos 3 y obtenemos
la raíz cuadrada de lo que está en la
derecha la raíz cuadrada de lo que está
en la derecha sería x sobre 3 - 2x y
saquemos la calculadora para hacer las
otras operaciones la raíz cuadrada de
2.9 por 10
la menos 3 es igual
redondeamos eso a 0.0 54 será mucho más
fácil esto redondeado tenemos cero punto
cero
54 nuestra meta es obtener el valor de x
es obtener la solubilidad molar podemos
multiplicar ambos lados por 3 - 2x
y cuando hacemos eso tendríamos esto
por lo que tenemos que multiplicar 0.54
por 3 y si redondease eso tendrás
aproximadamente 0.16 y 0.0 54 por 2 es
aproximadamente 0 punto
tenemos 0.16 0.11 x es igual a x tenemos
que 0.16 es igual a tenemos a las 12 x
en un solo lado
esta es una equis y esto es 0.11 x 1 x
0.11 x es 1 punto 11 x y ahora tenemos
que encontrar el valor de x haremos los
cálculos aquí tenemos 0.16 dividido
entre 1.11 y eso es igual a 0.14
x es igual a 0.14 que es un valor
aproximado debido a todas las veces que
redondeamos esta es la concentración
cierto esta es nuestra solubilidad molar
si volvemos aquí arriba
x igual a
0.14 molar esa es nuestra concentración
de ión complejo en solución en
equilibrio
esa es la solubilidad molar del cloruro
de plata es 0.14 molar
ahora regresamos al inicio y comparemos
la solubilidad es molares en agua pura
la solubilidad molar del cloruro de
plata es 1.3 por 10 a la menos 5 molar
lo que no es muy soluble pero ahora
tenemos al amoniaco presente
incrementamos la solubilidad y acabamos
de obtener una sola bilidad molar de
0.14 molar y obviamente 0.14 molar es
mucho mayor que 1.3 por 10 a la menos 5
así que la formación de unión complejo
incrementa la solubilidad de nuestro
compuesto poco soluble cloruro de plata